more than a foot of rain in Texas is
flooding roads and forcing water rescues
flash flood watches are and warnings are
in effect this morning
Courtney zubowski in is in Corpus
Christi which is under a flash flood
warning Courtney good morning
yeah we're in middle of that warning
right now as you can see this water
rushing into the intersection this is
actually the area where we saw water
rescues last night many Texans many of
those still recovering from hurricane
Harvey are being affected by these heavy
rains in Corpus Christi the fire
department was spread across the city
forcing and helping drivers to get out
of their cars many of them had to
abandon their cars in Port Arthur more
than 12 inches of rain flooded streets
forcing drivers to abandon their cars in
the middle of roadways and more than a
dozen homes in Orange County were
damaged after rising floodwaters rushed
in many of these homes flooded during
Hurricane harvey last August and were in
the process of being rebuilt heavy
thunderstorms are expected in this area
through Thursday and the flooding
threats continues scale
thank you very much Courtney doing that
without an umbrella and driving three
hours to get there we really appreciate
it thank you